philipson matter sera knew what access
to the vault and they know from their
months of reconnaissance which man holds
the keys
assistant manager John Villa grana he's
crouching behind the counter to get to
him
mater Serrano has to blast his way
through a bulletproof security door it's
only designed to withstand small arms
fire and I can feel the the nozzle the
rifle being placed on my back he hit me
with the with the rifle and the side of
the hand like I mean business and I said
well let's go to the ball John unlocks
the vault and opens the lockers storing
the cash
there's nothing like the amount of money
the gunmen are expecting to fort
criminals
Bank of America has been varying the
times that it delivers cash today's
supply has yet to arrive
I'm not emptying in the amount of cash
out of you maybe he was expecting I can
feel it in his tone
now he's needed a more aggressive he's
saying where's all of it I want you to
open up all you know he got upset so
what does he do he opens fire in all the
money that's in that cabinet
and I could see he's now believing me
he's all of a sudden got very quiet but
now he's putting his nozzle on me and I
was thinking well you know this is this
is it
this is really it for me now Wow
can't be it's too soon you know I didn't
even say goodbye to my daughter I didn't
outside officers call for every
available ambulance they fear multiple
casualties it's exactly eight minutes
since the start of the robbery
time for the gunman to make their
getaway
they've got $300,000 a fraction of what
they'd expected matter sera new exits
the building's south door Phillips the
North Philips expected a few police cars
to be just arriving
he appears stunned to see dozens of
officers waiting to shoot them down they
cover every escape route blocking off
junctions north and south of the bank
the police have cornered the robbers but
they've no idea what Phillips has in
mind
he loads the police